(string music)
- Oh, hi.
Um, I'll just be a minute.
I am so excited to
introduce you to my guest,
Margaret-
- James!
It's James, James Barry,
because I am a man.
Margaret is a woman's name,
and I am most definitely,
undoubtedly a man.
- Sure.
- I've got rippling
muscles and a huge penis.
Look at the way I sit.
See that?
It's nice, huh?
- Anyway, Dr. James Barry
is one of the very first
female doctors-
- Male, I am a man!
- Okay.
(orchestral, stately music)
James Margaret Berry is born
to a super progressive family,
so progressive that
they give her the name
of her dead uncle and then
send her off to medical school.
- They passed me off
as a teenage boy.
It was very easy.
- Are you sure he's
actually a boy?
Seems very feminine.
- He is wearing pants.
- [Both] He's a man.
- I head off to the Crimean War,
where I prove myself to
be a most talented doctor.
Next!
- James performs the
first ever C-section
where both the mother
and child live.
- And I'm one of
the first doctors
to practice good hygiene.
Who knew shitting on
your hand and putting it
near an open wound was bad?
Oh, yeah.
I did.
(yells)
(baby cries)
You're welcome.
- Bye.
For over 40 years, nobody
knew that James lived
privately as a woman.
Living with a secret
like this make James
prone to outbursts,
and he was known
to have a very, very short fuse.
- No, I don't!
That's a fucking lie!
(yells and screams)
Take it back, take it back!
(yells)
Ahh, lots better.
- Dr. James Berry, a lesson
in courage and perseverance.
- Did I ever tell you
about that time someone
made fun of my voice?
- Let me guess.
They met the sharp
end of your tongue?
- I bloody shot them.
- [Host] James, no!
- Oh, relax, I
didn't use that gun.
I used this one.
- Oh, my God, James!
(intense music)